les cherry dans tpm pelo mac ce soir on
va parler maintenant de chirurgie
esthétique sept à huit a consacré un
reportage tout entier à ce sujet on va
on avec nos plateaux un témoignage voilà
d'une personne qui était avec nous merci
merci d'être là et merci ni aux anars
voilà qui est un des chirurgiens les
plus connus et johan merci d'être avec
nous on va entendre votre témoignage
dans un instant mais regardez juste un
petit récapitulatif c'est parti
dimanche dernier une partie de
l'émission sept à huit été consacrée au
phénomène du moment
le docteur miami un chirurgien
esthétique qui filme ses opérations et
les diffuse sur ce match at avec plus de
2 millions de followers il est devenu
une véritable star et les gens se
pressent dans son cabinet de retour dans
la salle d'opération avec un cas très
intéressant aujourd'hui cette femme a
perdu beaucoup de poids et elle a
beaucoup de poids en trop
une façon de rendre la chirurgie ludique
avec des photos amusantes des vidéos
décalées et un univers qui fait oublier
le côté violent et dangereux des
opérations bonjour c'est michael alias
dr mialon suivez moi sur mon snapshot du
mardi le meilleur jour de la semaine les
stars elles aussi ont de plus en plus de
facilité à aborder ce sujet à l'instar
par exemple des soeurs kardashian il y à
peu c'est élise lucet qui consacrait un
numéro de cash investigations au dessous
du scandale des implants mammaires
défaillant un document percutant une
forme de cancer un lymphome anaplasique
à grandes cellules directement lié aux
implants mammaires alors entre stars
décomplexée scandale sanitaire est raté
la chirurgie esthétique est elle plutôt
un rêve ou un cauchemar
alors tu obliges esthétique du rêve au
cauchemar merci signer ouanna d'être
avec nous et johan alors vous vous êtes
fait connaître en participant au prince
de l'amour 4 télé réalité2 excellente
chaîne w9 vous êtes une victime de la
chirurgie on vous a opéré pour une
liposuccion et ça a très mal tourné
votre expérience a été un cauchemar vous
avez fait l'opération malheureusement
dans mon pays en tunisie fin du mois aux
deux pays la france et la tunisie
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait je
suis parti le première fois ça s'est
bien passé avec une autre clinique et je
suis reparti une deuxième fois pour
peaufiner le travail et donc j'ai fait
une liposuccion et elle m'a perforé
trois artères donc du coup je chantais
plus mon pied lendemain je leur ai dit
et mon pied l'effroi ge sont plus mon
pied mais non y'a rien c'est pas grave
donc je suis reparti comme ça on
souffrent et j'ai dû faire opérer
d'urgence en france parce que mes
artères étaient bouchés donc j'ai fait
une ischémie aiguë fou et elle m'a dit
que j'avais échappé de peu à perdre ma
jambe ou à mourir ça j'ai pris l'avion
avec des artères bouchées
alors si nous à nous donner voilà des
informations dans un instant alors donc
chirurgie esthétique rêve ou cauchemar
vous nous dire ce que vous en pensez
on va revenir sur le docteur miami qui
reçoit la visite de caliburn c'est une
influence y ait une influence aux
australes est très suivie sur les
réseaux qui souhaitent se refaire la
poitrine et la raison est assez
surprenante vous allez voir c'est ouf ça
aussi ça a été très dur de passer d'une
poitrine avec sa thèse à une poitrine
sont mes followers ont vu la différence
donc mais en fait il veut toujours que
je sois au top sur instagram
je prends beaucoup de photos et je dois
contrôler mon image 24 heures sur 24
ça me met beaucoup de pression donc je
me suis dit que pour avoir plus
confiance en moi et pour le boulot il
fallait que je remette les prothèses
docteur ohana c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut
dire parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya des
interventions qui c'est quoi les
interventions les plus pratiquées
aujourd'hui c'est ça reste la
liposuccion et les implants mammaires
d'allégro rebondir sur ce qui s'est
passé en tunisie avec magna avec johan
avec johan il faut bien voir que
comme dans toutes les professions il ya
des gens excellents des gens moins
excellent et pour être excellent il faut
des longues études en france et bac + 15
pour être changé en or
oui à bac + c'est à dire on est on est
chirurgien mais oui on commence à
travailler en privé ou autres pavant 34
35 ans ah ouais on accompagne ont
beaucoup et après concours après
concours chaque année c'est pas un petit
parcours et il faut faire toute la
médecine puis tout le spécialiste a été
chargée qu'elle puis la chirurgie
plastique
ça donne des garanties c'est pas pour
autant qu'on est excellent mais ça donne
des garanties dans le cadre d'un voyage
en tunisie organisé par une agence de
voyages sans connaître le nom du
chirurgien qui va l'opérer sans avoir
fait la consultation longtemps avant
avec l'anesthésiste pour dépister un
risque qu'elle avait peut-être des
troubles de la coagulation
je ne sais rien mais arrivés se faire
opérer et bien ça présente d'énormes
risques
retournée comme cela et si on touche
trois artères c'est qu'on n'a pas tardé
version d'anatomie alors tout ça pour
économiser de l'argent
tout ça parce que c'est un peu moins
cher en tunisie c'est un peu moins cher
johan c'est moins cher mais beaucoup
moins cher de combien j'en bave du coup
moi j'ai pas payer parce que j'ai fait
passer normalement oui c'est normal du
coup mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
cher et finalement bas c'est le même
prix les cliniques la ba devait faire à
la romaine de vacances et le voyage pour
le maintenant écoper en france alors
alors on va regarder vous allez voir ce
docteur la docteure miami lui il a une
spécialité c'est de filmer ses
opérations en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux
et franchement si vous regardez il faut
avoir le coeur bien accroché regarde on
se retrouve au bloc opératoire avec
aujourd'hui une liposuccion et un
changement d'implants mammaires des
vidéos brut aux images souvent très
trash sans filtre ni censure il a été le
premier chirurgien au monde a osé le
succès a été phénoménal
en un mois il est devenu l'une des stars
du réseau social l'accord dépasserait
exactement vous comprenez qu'on filme
les opérations dr anna alors nous
n'avons pas le droit de communiquer
comme cela paraît france a pas le droit
de faire de publicité des chirurgiens ou
les médecins en général c'est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs que la tunisie est en
première page sur tous les sites
internet
parcequ'il tente avec les prix c'est
d'ailleurs les agences qui organise cela
et qui payent des jeunes chirurgiens qui
démarre parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore
leur clientèle tout cela est aberrant
en france heureusement gare le conseil
de l'ordre des médecins qui créé des
garde-fous et on ne peut ni filmée de
façon un peu un peu exagéré comme ça
c'est un peu fort un pour moi ni faire
de la publicité
la meilleure publicité c'est le bouche à
oreille c'est les résultats qui se
transmettent de patient en patient alors
c'est comme ça alors justement alors il
ya des trucs aussi complètement fou il
ya plein de personnes qui veulent
ressembler absolument à leur star
préférée par exemple ya un mec qui
s'appelle toby sheldon qui a dépensé
plus de cent mille dollars pour
ressembler à justin bieber regardez
voilà le gard à 100 mille dollars et il
ressemble plus à justin beiber cent
mille dollars
il ya un fan à rtl qui a fait plus de 50
opérations pour ressembler une fan pour
ressembler à angelina jolie
regardez regardez aussi c'est un truc
quand vous avez ça quelqu'un qui vient
vous voir vous dit non c'est pas mal non
pas ces maladies mentales qu'on appelle
la dysmorphophobie bas et qui touche 1 %
de la demande que nous avons changé
c'est x que nous avons des belles
toilettes lorsque vous dites non je te
le fais pas ab il ira voir ailleurs
il n'est pas question d'accepter c'est
une folie toute façon serait condamné
parce que s'il a des complications le
chirurgien doit avoir des pistes et
sauve ce genre de problème mental qui
est la dysmorphophobie il aurait dû
l'envoyer à des psys avant alors
regardez un truc ya jordan 23 ans
lui il a dépensé 120 mille euros pour
ressembler à kim kardashian une barre à
regarder c'est ouf
il a fait quelques mois j'aurais fait au
feutre années j'allais dire j'aurais
fait comme ça frères j'aurais pris deux
balles c'est toi même c'est un truc de
ouf
une mère et sa fille qui ont dépensé
près de 80000 euros pour ressembler à
barbie
regardez à la maman oui c'est la bouche
ou à chaque fois la bouche à bouche on
dirait des mérous frère rodrigo alvarez
qui a dépensé 500 mille dollars dont
plus de 58 opérations de chirurgie pour
ressembler à son idole
kane le mari de barbie regardez regardez
vous pouvez regarder lui bon lui il est
pas il n'est pas si mal n'est pas si mal
alors on parle ils offriront du docteur
miami ils reçoivent d'aller voir une
patiente qui appelle christina et qui
décide après son accouchement de tout
refaire ça lui a coûté trente mille
euros pour 6 heures d'intervention
regardez ok christina on récapitule
en gros on refait tout on va remonter
les saints faire une liposuccion un
lifting du bas du corps avec une
incision qui fera le tour de votre
talent on va aussi faire un lifting des
cuisses et remettez les façonner
l'opération réalisée sous anesthésie
générale est facturé 30 mille euros elle
va durer six heures vous êtes prête
ok demain vous aurez l'impression qu'un
camion vous a roulé dessus
mais vous pouvez le faire vous allez
d'abord me détester mais d'ici un mois
vous m'adore que la fête commence
ces ouvrages sur wii moi j'ai une
question pour jouer là est ce que vous
n'avez pas joué à l'adresse que vous
avez porté plainte contre la clinique
suite aux préjudices que vous avez subie
et bah justement parce qu'en plus ils
ont fait de la diffamation sur moi après
donc ils essayent de me tuer après une
enfance mais c'est compliqué trouver un
avocat qui s'occupe de savants franges
en a détruit en tunisie mais on vous
avait rien fait et vous développez des
opérations pour l'instant alors il ya un
autre truc que fait le docteur miami et
donc qui fait pas d'ailleurs il le fait
mais très peu de gens le font c'est les
is it le gonflement du pénis
voilà je vous dis juste un peu il s'en
cache pas benoît dubois nous l'indiqué à
effet de serre et ils sont capables
commence à se faire un par ligne et que
c'était temporaire ça dure 2 1 ou 2 ans
à 1 ou 2 ans ça veut dire ta meuf elle
se marie avec kwame nord
et au bout de deux ans à l'arrivée c'est
la longueur là c'est la largeur à merci
au courant apparemment ils sont partis
au cap d'agde ensemble l'année dernière
regardez alors ta question pendant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a une momie
makeover une liposuccion une
augmentation mammaire et un pénis qui
laisse un pénis qu'on va faire grossir
regardez-la la honte de le dire elle
rougit il y a quinze jours
carlos a filmé un élargissement de pénis
qu'il a réalisé on le voit injecter un
produit semblable au botox qui permet de
faire grossir le sexe c'est fou oui
valérie mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'aux états unis le monde de la
chirurgie notamment à miami est
extrêmement concurrentiel
la publicité à la télé ne suffit plus
parce qu'ils ont effectivement le droit
alors que nous on n'a pas le droit
français donc maintenant ils utilisent
tous les réseaux sociaux sur snapfish
instagram et c est que ce docteur qu'on
surnomme docteur my ami de tout le pays
on vient pour l'eau le voit faire opérer
par lui alors docteur kelly la demande
la plus folle où les demandes les plus
folles que vous ayez eu vous si vous
avez deux verdez c'est celle de
ressembler à un autre personnage et pour
nous c'est une maladie c'était quoi j'en
ai eu quoi comme personnage vous a
demandé qui est dricot macias n'a rien
fait quoi johnny hallyday juste après
les après son décès on commence à faire
de plus en plus de péno plastique est
chargé du pénis mais comme le dit
mademoiselle ça joue sur l'élargissement
de la circonférence
il a très peu sur la longueur a qu'un
petit ligaments qu'on peut libérer
s'allonge de 2 cm à peu près au repos où
on a de plus et donc j'ai un truc à dire
pour vous vraiment vous de plus de ça
fait 4 je vous le dis est ce que vous
avez déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
est-ce que voilà où est ce que vous avez
honte de le dire du tout mais alors pas
lire les plats moi j'ai par ailleurs été
bougés fait les cheveux et les paupières
abattu à gauche et pop y ait un peu de
chemin trop de cheveux très bien mais
faut le lire bernard
non je l' ai jamais fait mais je suis
pas contre c'est vrai vous dire faire
quoi moi les paupières haoues un peu
lourde mais paupières non là ça c'est
parce que messmer vous êtes notice est
content
vous mais moi je veux me faire la tétée
l'été tu es d'accord ray cooney coffret
tout d'un coup ah oui après j'ai
l'impression en fait que ce sont les
fins les plus belles femmes qui ont
recours à la chirurgie esthétique et ce
qui me fait peur c'est qu'elles ont
recours de plus en plus tôt et donc
évidemment elle multiplie les on voit
maintenant les ravages de la santé oms
qui ont accumulé des choses et il ya eu
plus caravage
il ya eu un drame qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière une célèbre star du raï
ou harry manar a sombré dans le coma
après une anesthésie
voilà son coeur à la chine il avait été
admis à demi pour une liposuccion
abdominale et il est il est mort voilà
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des cc voilà
ccc ximun croyable voilà ce qui peut se
passer en tout cas docteur es ce que
vous avez des conseils à donner juste
aux téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices
qui nous regarde pas ce que ça devient
extrêmement dangereuse qui se passe chez
roger le meilleur conseil que je
donnerais c'est d'écouter le médecin
traitant qui est un conseil le
chirurgien un chirurgien n'est pas là
pour faire du chiffre d'affaires est
opérée au maximum il faut s'enlever ça
de la tête
un patient sur deux qui vient demander
êtes impatients que l'on refuse et à qui
on dit c'est trop tôt
quand c'est trop tôt comme adam le dis
on reporte la com alors faire plusieurs
gestes en même temps nous on ne le fait
pas c'est interdit plus on multiplie les
gestes puis on augmente le risque de
phlébite et d'embolie pulmonaire
c'est ce qu'a eu cette personne par une
lipoaspiration les grosses l'ipo vaut
mieux les faire en deux fois
il y à un nombre de règles auxquelles
nous sommes astreints donc écouté les
conseils du chirurgien prendre de trois
à vie s'il le faut et sa décision après
johan est ce que vous allez refaire la
chose d'esthétique ou est-ce que vous
êtes vraiment traumatisé alors moi je
suis pas contre pas vraiment mais je
suis honnête je suis pas content mais
par contre je n'irai pas dans un autre
pays
merci ça s'est bien passé la première
fois et a convié fait quoi la première
fois j'avais fait les sai nippo d'accord
et après j'ai fait à betty d'en refaire
une chorale parce qu'elle arrive on
dirait qu'elle arrive dans un bar tu
mets 200 aînés
je reste là reste coi catherine pénis
pas si la série dames et c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'en plus on phélippeau
en oublie de manger sainement derrière
ou de faire du sport alors que tout ça
j'aurais pu faire du sport et ne
bougeait pas de refaire une
donc si j'ai un conseil à donner c'est
enfin déjà que ça fait mal
faut arrêter les passe que j'enterre
était non ça fait pas mal il avait dit
mike voilà merci non mais alors on va
voir ce qu'on pense des téléspectateurs
tiens voilà qu'est ce qu'il dit alors la
chirurgie esthétique cauchemar 86% est
ce que ça me fait du mal ce genre de
sondage pas du tout d'accord du tout
d'abord à moi ça me fait pas du tout de
mal de parce que je vois les
consultations et demain ce sera l'un
verse
l'accord sera 86% de rêve et 14% les
chirurgies esthétiques même avec
certains risques existent dans n'importe
quoi n'importe l'utilisation d'un
dispositif implantable comme les
implants mammaires ou instinct dans le
coeur c'est quand même très rare les
complications par rapport aux bénéfices
qu'en de bénéfices risques est le seul
élément qui doit faire trancher et sa
videra pas du tout les consultations de
médecins esthétiques au contraire et
julien lepers bien merci parce qu on air
on doit il est 21h sans suite est ce que
le docteur est ce que vous avez eu accès
enfin recours vous même à la wii c'est
vrai c'est une bonne fille
comme vous n'êtes pas là même qui peut
le cheveux complètement chemin il en a
pris sous jean michel maire